[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم حين تختارك الاقدار لتكون طالبا
في المدرسه المولويه في الرباط وزميلا
لولي العهد انذاك الملك الحالي محمد
السادس فان مسارا جديدا ومغاير للحياه
التي الفها الاولاد سيكون بانتظارك هذا ما
حدث مع ضيفنا المثقف والاكاديمي المغربي
البارز الدكتور حسن اريد في العام
1977 حين كان تقريبا في الرابعه عشره من
عمره من بين نخبه من الطلبه المغاربه تم
اختياره لتفوقه كي يكون طالبا في المدرسه
التي تصنع الملوك والامراء في المملكه في
تقليد الملكي يرساه الملك محمد الخامس
لابنه الحسن الثاني ومن جاء بعده وما كان
من ابني مدينه تازموريت الا الاستجابه
والسير في هذا الطريق الذي يمنح صاحبه
مزامله الملك القادم ومعرفه النخبه عن قرب
تدرج الدكتور اريد في المدرسه الاولويه ثم
التحق بكليه الحقوق والعلوم السياسيه
لينال منها الاجازه في القانون العام ومع
تولي الملك محمد السادس مقاليد الحكم عين
كمتحدث رسمي باسم القصر الملكي ومن بعدها
واليا على مكناس واخيرا كمؤرخ رسمي
للمملكه المغربيه قبل ان يطلب ضيفنا
اعفاءه في سابقه ميزه الرجل وعبرت عن زهده
بالمناصب والحظوه ورغبته بالمضي قدما في
مسيره الثقافه والفكر والادب في هذه
الحلقه استعرض مع الرجل هذه المسيره وما
فيها من محطات هامه ولافته وكيف تشكل
معرفيا وثقافيا في ظل مسار موازي للسلطه
والحكم ولماذا قرر الابتعاد اخيرا وطلب
الاعفاء على ان اتناول معه في الحلقه
القادمه مسيرته الفكريه ومؤلفاته العده
التي ابحر فيها في عوالم الادب والفكر
والثقافه الدكتور حسن اريد ضيف المقابله
فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الكرام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته اهلا بكم الى هذه الحلقه الجديده
من المقابله ستضيف فيها الكاتب والمثقف
والسياسي ورجل الدوله المغربي الدكتور حسن
وليد مرحبا بك دكتور شكرا عاده في
المقابله يعني مختلف التجارب تكون غنيه
ومميزه ومنوعه اضافه لذلك تجربه الدكتور
حسن غايه في الغنى حقيقه نود في في حلقتين
ان نستعرض هذه المحطات مسيره مثقف
وتحولاته والمحطات الرئيسيه منها نفهم
التجربه ومنها نفهم ايضا الحاله بشكل عام
حاله الثقافيه نبدا من الولاده والنشاه
الدكتور حسن اين كانت ولادتكم طبعا مطلع
الستينات في اواخر 62 وهو في ديسمبر
62 نهايه 62
في مدينه كانت حينها قارعه في الجنوب
الشرقي وكانت تسمى قصر السوق قصر السوق
قصر السوق انشاها بالاساس المقيم العام
الاول
في واحد كانت تسمى واحه النغره
واصولي تعود الى قريه على جنبات نهر جيج
تسمى تزموريت والاسم امازيغي وهو تصغير
لازمور تازموريت
وازمور هو المكان الذي يغرس فيه الزيتون
وقد غرست هناك
ونبته هناك لم اغرى
من هاته القريه
ولدت في قصر السوق ودرست بها شطرا من
طفوله
وشطرا اخر عند اخوالي لان امي امازيغيه
ودرست في ميدلت او في قريه
والدتك امازيغيه ماذا عن والدك بعربي مزيج
يعني بعربي
وحافظ للقران ودرس اللغه العربيه معلما
ولذلك انا يعني مزدوج اللسان والوجدان هل
ثمه حدود فاصله نهائيه بين هويتين
الامازيغيه والعربيه بالنسبه للمغاربه
المختلطين مع بعضهم البعض هو صعب هناك
مناطق لها هويه خاصه ولكن هناك مناطق فيها
تداخل
وبالاخص الجنوب الشرقي لان البليه
الاساسيه امازيغيه
واتى العنصر العربي في القرن الرابع عشر
من خلال هجره بني معقل فصار فيه نوع من
التزاوج والتمازج في علاقه فسيفساء ولذلك
يمكن ان تجد قريه يتكلم اهلها العربيه
وعلى بعد
فراسخ او اقل من كيلومتر يتكلمون
الامازيغيه وقريه يتكلمون العربيه
والامازيغيه ما اثر هذه الدماء في في داخل
الدكتور حسن الامازيغيه والعربيه هويتيا
وجدانيا هو حقيقه انا عربي اللسان
والوجدان والقضايا
وامازيغي اللسان والوجدان والقضايا وهو
شان كل المغاربه في اعتقادي انهم عرب
امازيغ او امازيغ عرب فانا
لست انا عربي ولكن لست عربيا فقط
وانا امازيغي ولست امازيغيا فقط واظن بانه
هو الشعور العام في اعتقادي
لكل ساكنه شمال افريقيا وما كان يسمى في
التاريخ ببلاد البربر فالعنصر او الماده
هي امازيغيه وتلقحت بالعنصر العربي لكن
المنفتح على الثقافتين والمنتمي لثقافتين
وكان المسؤوليه اكبر في تلقي الاشياء في
طفولته في فهم الاشياء في معرفتها عبر
لغتين عبر مسارين عبر فهمين هناك جوانب
ذاتيه نتركها للاشخاص ان يحددوه هوياتهم
وانتسابهم كما جاءوا
ولكن هناك رؤيه موضوعيه انه لا نستطيع ان
نفهم شمال افريقيا او بلاد المغرب او سمها
كما شئت بدون
العروبه لانها جزء من ولكن بدون
الامازيغيه كذلك مثلا اعطيك مثال يعني
اغلب الاسماء او اسماء الاماكن
كما تسمى اغلبها في شمال افريقيا امازيغي
خذ مثلا يعني
من سيوى الى المغرب كلها تالا مثلا في
تونس جربه الطاوين في زي وزو
فياريتي تيشلا اكادير
فاس مكناس كلها اسماء امازيغيه هذه
الاسماء لم تسمي نفسها هناك اشخاص اطلقوا
هاته الاسماء ولا يمكن ان تكون هذه
الاسماء الا بلسان هؤلاء فالجغرافيا
تحادثنا والتاريخ يحدثنا فهناك عناصر
موضوعيه ولذلك ثم بالنسبه للغه التي
نتكلمها يعني هي بالاساس عربيه من حيث
المعجم ولكنها امازيغيه من حيث التركيب
ولذلك يجد العربي في المشرق بعد الصعوبه
ان يفهم المغرب مثلا يعني
نقول يعني يعني واحد الرجل واحد عربيه رجل
عربيه ولكن واحد الرجل يعني التركيب غير
عربي تركيب امازيغيه
يعني بل احيانا تسمع واحد المراه
يعني
في تناقض يعني واحد المراه يعني مازال
ماجه مازال عربيه جاء عربيه ولكن يعني
بالامازيغيه فالتركيب الذي نستعمله في
شمال افريقيا متاثر كثيرا به حتى مثلا
اقرب ناس ارتباطا بالثقافه العربيه هم بني
حسان وحتى هم يعني لغتهم لا تسلم من تاثير
الامازيغي الرجل يقال له ارجاز يا الياس
هي الرجل يعني في في الحسانيه فاللغه
حاضره الاماكن ولكن اهم شيء في البنيه
الذهنيه
ولذلك انا في اعتقادي لا يمكن لعاقل بنظره
موضوعيه
ان يذهل عن العنصر الاماسيقي طبعا انا
بالنسبه الينا انظر الى الامر نظر التناقض
ولكن تمازج يعني اردت ان اسالك دكتور يعني
هذا التزاوج والتجاور عبر قرون هل افضل
يوم الى الى اندماج وحاله تعدديه اما زالت
بذور صدام ماء هنا وهناك تظهر
اظن
لا الواقع هو انه صار تمازج ولذلك حقيقه
يعني هناك مقوله ماثوره
لعبد الحميد بن بادس في الجزائر وهو يعني
من انشا جمعيه علماء المسلمين قال عن جمله
ماثوره شعب الجزائر مسلم والى العروبه
ينتسب فاذا
الشعور العام هو الاسلام اما العروبه فهي
انتساب هذا هو
والعروبه لا يعني في بلاد المغرب لا تنفصل
عن الاسلام طبعا صارت في مؤثرات اخرى
ومن دون شك ان التجربه الاستعمار كادع الى
اخره كان لها تاثير كذلك
وبدون شك انها ركزت على هذه العنصر ويعني
عنصر التميز
ومن دون شك انه بعد الاستقلال كذلك صار
فيه نوع من الاهمال هذا المكون واعتبر
بانه
كان رده فعله كان يعتبر انه قد يكون مطيه
مستعمر
ولذلك ذهب الاتجاه الى التوحيد والتعريب
وتم تبين خطر هذا الخطا هذا التوجه يعني
الان يعني
يشهد المرء نعم الاعتراف هل يعني بلغت
الحكومات على الاقل لا استطيع ان اتكلم
الى بنسبه للمغرب ولكن هناك وعي بانه لا
يمكن التفريط في هذا
اعود للدكتور حسن ونشاته الاسره اسره
متوسطه الحال والدكم كان معلما انا معلما
بالتالي واضح انه كان في اثر ثقافي منذ
اللحظه هو والدي
ولندرج في وسط تقليدي وحفظ القران
وكان معلما يدرس اللغه العربيه ومن دون شك
ان هذا العامل اثر فيه في مسار من دون شك
يعني كون والدي كان معلما للغه العربيه من
دون شك انه اثر في معرفه للغه العربيه وفي
تشبع بهاته اللغه ومحبه لها وهو يعني كما
يكون اي معلم من وسط متوسط يعني انما في
البيئه التي درجت فيها لم تكن هناك
تفاوتات منطقه بسيطه يعني لم تكن هناك
تفاوتات بين يعني
لا اقول يعني بين عليا القوم والبسطاء من
القول لم تكن هناك تفاوتات كبرى يعني
نهايه الستينات بدايه يعني كانت ثوره
ايدولوجيا في العالم العربي هذه التيارات
هذه الافكار هل القت بظلالها على نشات
الدكتور حسن اكيد اول شيء انا اذكر حرب
اكتوبر كنت حينها صبيا
واظن بان وعي توقد مع حرب اكتوبر العاشره
كنت تقريبا في العاشره في العاشره وكنا
نسمع يعني طائره الفونتوم
وهات الكلمات التي ثغره الى اخره فهاتي
اول جولان الى اخره فهاتي اشياء لم يكن
حينها يعني التلفزيون في هذه المنطقه التي
ولدت بها كان الكبار يستمعون الى الراديو
ونتلقى هذه الاخبار اعتقد بان هذه اللحظه
تكلمت عنها في رواه مكه كان لها تاثير
عميق في في وعيه وفي وجداني في 73 كذلك في
مارس
ووقعت توغل عناصر مسلحه مشبعه بالقوميه
العربيه في المنطقه التي ولدت بها يعني
وصارت فيها مداهمات واشتباكات مسلحه مع
السلطه مع السلطه واثرت تاثيرا بالغا في
المنطقه لانه بعدها فشل التمرد وصارت فيها
اعتقالات
وعاشت المنطقه على سلسله اعتقالات هل
تلمست طريقا ايدولوجيا نحو اليسار نحو
التوجه الاسلامي ما الى ذلك ام حافظت على
مسارا وسيط بيننا منطقي الاشياء بالنظر
الى طبيعه الاسره ان اكون اميل الى توجه
الاسلامي هذا هو حقيقه الامر يعني لانه
اسره محافظه مواظبه على الصلاه هذا منطق
الاشياء
ولكن من دون شك انه
بالاخص في مرحله معينه كنت اقرب ما اكون
الى القوميه العربيه يعني قد يستغرب البعض
ولكن حقيقه اثر القوميه العربيه كان قويا
واستشعرته بالاخص
حينما اجتاحت القوى الاسرائيليه فيما سمي
بعمليه السلام في الجليل دخلت الى لبنان
وازاحت يعني
واخرجت منظمه التحليل الفلسطينيه بعدما
اظن بان هذه الفتره تشكل في وجداني يعني
النقطه الاقوى في الشعور بالانتماء الى في
القوميه العربيه جزء من مسار اكيد يعني في
سن الثالثه عشره انتقلت للرباط في المدرسه
المولويه وهذه مدرسه يدرس فيها الامراء
وابناء الملوك ويختار طلاب من المغرب من
مختلف من عموم المغرب للدراسه معه كيف جرى
هذا الامر ودرست مع الملك محمد السادس
حينما كان ولي العهد نعم درست كان هناك
تقليد لربما يعود الى الى القديم يعني ان
ان الامراء ما يسمى بمصطلح مخزن الشرفه
من من ابناء الشعب المغربي
ان يكونوا ممثلين لبعض الجهات
تفوق اكيد اكيد اعتقد يعني معايير التفوق
لا ادري ايها ولكن على كل حال اعتقد بان
الذين اختاروا وضعوا نصب اعينهم التفوق
وعامل السن وربما كذلك
اوساط مختلفه الى متنوعه في المدرسه اضافه
الى 11 11 تلميذ هذا هو العدد كيف كان
وقعها عليك اختيارك دكتور ان تكون طالبا
في المدرسه المولويه مع ولي عهد المغرب
والملك الحالي طبعا لن يكون الامر هينا
لانه حقيقه ان ينتقل الانسان من مجتمع الى
اخر يعني وبينهما
هو شاسعه اولا بالنظر الى ليس فقط جغرافيا
ولكن ثقافيا وحتى طبقيا لم يكن المساله
ولكن بدايه الوقت لا يمكن الى ان يستشعر
الانسان نوع من الفرح لانه قد امتياز وقد
يمنح
سبل الحضوى والنجاح مبدئيا مبدئيا يعني
الحياه اعقد من ذلك يعني وخيال الحياه
اكبر من خياليه والمستهدف فيها
ايجاد حاضنه لولي العهد في ذلك الوقت ولا
ايضا حتى الطلبه الاخرين في صناعه نخب
سياسيه وهذا مجال دوله طبعا ليس بالضروره
ان كل من يكون فيها قد يكون عنصرا من
النخبه ولكن من دون شك ان تكون حاضره مثل
ما تفضلت يعني ان تكون صوره للمجتمع
لانه عنصر لا يمكن في نهايه المطاف ان يتم
الا من خلال عناصر متشابهه في السن وكذلك
يعني يعني هناك اشياء لا يمكن ان تمرر الا
من خلال الاتراب احيانا يعني الاباء لا
يستطيعون ان الاصدقاء او لذلك يعني من دون
شك انه ان تكون حاضنه وهو تقليد مثل ما
قلت لك انه جرب كان قائما يعني في المخزن
القديم ولدينا شهادات عنه ثم كذلك
استنبتت التجربه مع المرحوم الحسن الثاني
والحسن الثاني كان يقول بانه مدرسه في
المدرسه درس في المدرسه المولويه وكانت له
جمله يقول معناها انه
خياله لم يعني حصر لكي يتبنى تعليما اخر
غير ذلك الذي يعني حصل عليه بالنسبه
لابنائه بمعنى اخر انه اراد ان يستنسخ
التجربه التي عاشها ودرس
لكم كطلبه حينما يعني تم نقلكم او
ذهابكم للرباط والدراسه مع ولي العهد هو
لا هو لم تكن اعتقد بانه
التعليمات التي اعطاها الملك
لهناك كان شخص وزير مكلف بتربيه الامراء
ولكن كان هناك مدير وكانت التعليمات
الصرامه لم يكن هناك يعني حيث ولا تمييز
هل كان يميز الملك ولي العهد كان يعني
يحظى بوضع استثنائي ابدا كانت تعليمات
الذي اعرف هو مثل ما قال لمدير المدرسه
ان الملك الحسن الثاني رحمه الله قال له
التعليم انت
والتربيه انا
عليك ان تعلم
باللغه الفرنسيه ان التعليم هو من مسؤوليه
مدير المدرسه ولكن تربيه الامراء على يعني
فهي من مسؤوليه الملك متى حدث احتكاك
الاول مع الملك المغربي
ينبغي القول ولي العهد حينها ولي العهد
كنا حينها
ثلله التحقت
يعني
في المدرسه وزارنا حينها ولي العهد لاول
مره نراه من لحم ودم يعني
وزارنا
مقدمه زميل لنا هديه وكانت عباره عن مصحف
من القران الكريم
وتناول معنا يعني ما يسمى العصرنيه
وكان حيا يعني لم يتكلم كثيرا ربما كان
يعني خجلا
ونحن كذلك لم نتحدث يعني تناول معنا يعني
يبدو بانه
كان متاثرا ولاحظ ان بعض العناصر كانت
تتكلم اللغه الفرنسيه
سهوا ورهوا ولم اكن من هؤلاء انا كانت
فرنسيه بحكم منطقه وبحكم اصولي يعني كنت
اتكلم الفرنسيه بلكنه قويه يعني لانني لا
اتكلم اكون اتكلم اللغه الفرنسيه وكان
عنصر التمايز هو اللغه الفرنسيه الذين
ولدوا في المدينه طبعا يتحدثونها بطلاقه
فكان هذا هو اللقاء
وتم يعني في ادب
واظن بتحفظ بعد ذلك بعد ذلك صارت الامور
هاديه اصبح زميل اصبح زميل يعني كنت
تشعرون بالفوارق يعني بالحدود لا لا لم
تكن هناك فروق يعني ربما الشيء الاساسي
[موسيقى]
ممكن هو فقط اللقب
كنا نناديه باسم
درجه عليه اولا فيما يسمى دار المخزن كنا
نسميه سيدي
هذا هو التمييز لم نكن نناديه باسمه
الشخصي ولا باسم لقبه ولي العهد
ووجدت بانه في بعض الاسر العريقه كان
لديهم هذا التقليد يسمونها بعضا من سميد
وكان هناك يعني بعض الاساتذه الذين كانوا
يسمونه باسمه الخاص سيدي محمد
[موسيقى]
في عام 1942 قرر العاهل المغربي الراحل
الملك محمد الخامس انشاء المدرسه المولويه
لاعداد خلفه الملك الحسن الثاني الذي كان
انذاك وليا للعهد
اسندت مهمه التدريس بالمدرسه الى نخبه من
المعلمين المعروفين لتهيئه ولي العهد كما
جرى بعنايه شديده اختيار عشره من ابناء
الشعب اشترط فيهم ان يكونوا اترابا لولي
العهد ومن الفئه العمريه نفسها وان يكونوا
من الاذكياء والمتفوقين دراسيا ومن
الموالين للعرش هذا بالاضافه الى تمتع
اسرهم بسمعه جيده
وعلى الخطى نفسها سار العاهل المغربي
السابق الملك الحسن الثاني مع نجله ولي
العهد محمد السادس قبل ان يصبح ملكا فدرس
مع اقرانه في احد صفوف المدرسه المولويه
وهو الامر الذي تكرر لاحقا مع ولي العهد
الحالي الامير الحسن الثالث
وتركز المقررات التي يتلقاها الدارسون
بالمدرسه على الهويه المغربيه من خلال
التعلم القران الكريم والفقه واللغه
العربيه الى جانب اللغه الفرنسيه وخلال
السنوات الاخيره استحدثت مواد دراسيه لم
تكن تدرس في السابق مثل صف تقنيه
المعلومات الذي يدرس الطلاب فيه اسس
التواصل والاعلام الاجتماعي مهمه المدرسه
المولويه لم تكن قاصره على اعداد الامراء
قبل الجلوس على عرش المغرب اذ عملت
بالتوازي على تخريج نخبه من المؤثرين
وصانع القرار الاقوياء بالمملكه ولاحقا لم
تعد المدرسه تقتصر على شخص ولي العهد حيث
عمد مسؤولها الى فتح فصل لكل من كبار
افراد العائله الملكيه
[موسيقى]
استمرت الدراسه مع ولي العهد حتى نهايه
المرحله الثانويه حتى
الجامعيه
اي نعم اي نعم
هل نشات علاقه خاصه بينكم دكتور وبينهم
على كل حال اظن بانه
كما قال الملك الحسن الثاني حينما مات
محمد الخامس
قال بانه دفن اباه ودفن كذلك ولي العهد
اظن بانه في مسار الملوك هناك مرحله حاسمه
بين قبل تولي الملك وبعضهم ولذلك يعني في
تلك الفتره كانت العلاقه طبيعيه يعني شخص
يتولى مسؤوليه الدوله لا يمكن الا ان يكون
يعني وفق ما تفرضه المسؤوليه يعني
فاظن بانه لا استطيع الحديث بالنسبه للملك
محمد السادس ولكن هناك مثل ما قلت ما قاله
الحسن الثاني عن نفسه انه حينما دفن اباه
دفن معه كذلك
الحسن الثاني يعني ان هذه الفتره انتهت
هل تم مواقف استثنائيه طوال هذه التجربه
مع ولي العهد انذاك
شيء تسجله الذاكره
والله الان اخذتني على حين غره يعني
اظن بانه لابد من مسافه لكي اتبين هذه
فالحياه السياسيه هي مثل لوحه يعني لا
يمكن ان نتبينها الى حينما
تولى الملك عينك ناطقا بسم الله نعم
اشتغلت يعني اشتغلت
ناطقا باسم القصر صحيح لفتره لماذا اختار
كما اسم القصر هل راى فيك معبرا عما يريده
من افكار برايك انا لا استطيع يعني ان اضع
نفسي في ذهني عن الاسباب ربما يمكن يعني
ان اخمن
لانه حينها كان هناك ناطق رسمي باسم
الحكومه وحتى لا يكون هناك خلط وربما تحدث
في اشياء لم يكن مخولا ان يتحدث عنها
ربما كانت يعني اشاره على انه للحكومه ان
تتكلم في القضايا التي تهمها وليس لها ان
تتكلم باسم باسم القصر على كل حال على كل
حال اظن بانه هاته هي السبب بين الزملاء
كان هناك شخصيات استمرت يعني معروف الان
في المشهد السياسي من دون شك طبعا يعني
ابرزهم بدون شك فؤاد عن الهمه الذي الان
يتولى منصب مستشار الملك وتولى رئاسه
الوزراء وانشاء الوزاره لا كان انشاء حزبا
سياسيه انشا حزبا سياسيا مع ثله يعني من
النشطه الى اخره استمرت انت الجامعه درست
في الكليه الحقوق دكتور لماذا اخترت
الحقوق والعلوم السياسيه هو اخترت الحقوق
لانه ولي العهد حين اختار الحقوق
واستمررت في دراسه معه
لم يكن اختيارا شخصيا لا لم يكن لا لم يكن
اختيار شخصي ولكن كان الاختيار الطبيعي
وهو الاختيار الذي لربما كان يستجيب حينها
مع منطق الاشياء كان الملك الحسن الثاني
وهو الذي كان يرسم تربيه
ونراد انه
لابد لرئيس الدوله ان يكون يدرس القانون
ليدافع عن بلده يمكن ان يجد المهندس ممكن
ان يجد الطبيب ولكن محتاج ان يدرس الحقوق
ليدافع عن بلده فلذلك درسنا الحقوق في
جامعه محمد الخامس باللغتين باللغه
العربيه وباللغه الفرنسيه مع ولي العهد
درسنا القسم او في الشطره كل الفريق كل
الطلبه الثلاثه كل كل الفريق او جزء منه
لان البعض اختار خيارا اخر مع الطلبه
المغاربه يعني درسنا في نفس الظروف التي
درس فيها الطلبه المغاربه مع اساتذه بعضهم
مغاربه وبعضهم من المشرق كان منهم اساتذه
مصريون وكان منهم عراقيون والسوريون بل
السودانيون كذلك دكتور هذا المسار مسار
استثنائي الدراسه مع الرجل الثاني في
الدوله في مدرسه المولويه مدرسه خاصه
برعايه القصر والملك
تترك اثر اخر على الانسان ما ابرز اثر
تركتها على اول شيء هو اكتشاف عوالم لا
يمكن ان تتاح لمسار عادي
لمعرفه معرفه معرفه طبعا معرفه اولا
التقلب في اوجه الحياه يعني تكسر تميزات
الطبقيه يعني تطل على اشياء لا تتاح لشخص
ان يعرفها
تعرف شخصيات كذلك يعني ليس من السهل يعني
لاي كان يعني عرفت النخبه كلها النخبه
عرفت يعني درست يعني لم حقيقه يعني لاول
مره كنت مذهولا ان ارى اشخاصا لم اكن
اراهم الا في التلفزيون وكان بعضهم اساتذه
وطبعوا المشهد الثقافي والسياسي يعني ان
يكون استاذ لك الحاج محمد الباحنيني الذي
كان وزيرا واستادا للملك الحسني الثاني
ليس بالشيء الهين ان يكون لديك استاذ مثلا
مثل محمد الفاسي
رجل وطني ومن مواقع وثيقه الاستقلال واول
وزير للتربيه الوطنيه واول من ادخل اللغه
العربيه في اليونسكو ليس امرا هينا ان
يكون مدير لك مثلا محمد شفيق واحد من
اعمده مركز
وزاره التربيه الوطنيه وواحد من منظري من
سيصبحون منظري للحركه الامازيغيه ليس شيئا
هذا يتيح لك طبعا يعني
تجربه فريده
لا تكون يعني حرا في في مسار في اختيارك
الى اخره سلوك ايضا خارج المدرسه وتحت
المسؤوليه يعني انت لا تستطيع ان تتصرف لا
كنا عاديين حينها والاقامه
في الاقامه كنا في الثانويه كانت عباره عن
داخليه المدرسه داخليه داخليه كنا نستيقظ
صباحا على الساعه السادسه صباحا
[موسيقى]
العام الدراسي
في يناير 77 والقى الحاج محمد بحنيني درسا
وكان حول المعلقات حضر الملك الحسن الثاني
وكان يحضر وهذا شيء مهم
حفل نهايه السنه كان يقام حفل نهايه السنه
ويحضر هو كان حريصا على حضوره وتقدم يعني
عروض مسرحيات اغاني باللغه العربيه
والفرنسيه وطبعا تبتدا اساسا
بالقران الكريم
وقبله خطبه
لعدد المنتسبين للمدرسه فقط فصلكم ام لا
كانت الفصل كان له خاص ولكن كانت هناك
فصول بالنسبه
لطالب بما فيهم
وكان هناك كذلك فصل الاميره
لاله مريم مع زميلاتها فصلان فقط في
المدرسه ثم بعد ذلك كانت هناك فصول
بالنسبه
لبعض
الاميرات ثم الامير مولاي رشيد التحق بنا
الامير وكنا في نفس البنايه
في هذه الاجواء الملكيه
وقطع ان تراها من زاويه اخرى بخلاف ما
يراه الناس
ولم اشعر اني لنفسي الا الى حينما شعرت
انني لم اعد يعني بعد ما تركت او استقلت
من مهمه او قدمت طلب الاعفاء حينها دكتور
حسن
ووضعت بين خيارين ان تدرس بنفس المسار او
ان تختط لنفسك مسارا طبيعيا مثل الطلب
الاخرين
لا استطيع ان اطرح هذا السؤال هذا السؤال
يعني اظن بانه من الحكمه ان يتقبل المرء
المسار الذي رسمته الحياه
منطق الاشياء هو انني كنت اميل الى
الرياضيات يقال عني انني كنت موهبا في
الرياضيات
وانا لدي حسا علميا اختارت الحياه شيئا
اخر ينبغي ان اقبله
وتفوقت فيه على كل حال ان اقبله تفوقت
وفيه اشياء اديت ثمنا على كل حال ولكن
ينبغي ان اقبله كما هو
ماذا كان سيكون مساري لا ادري ولا اظن
بانه من الحكمه ان اطرح هذا السؤال ثم بعد
انهاء حصولك على الاجازه الجامعيه اكملت
دراسه التعليب تعليمك العالي حصلت على
الدكتوراه التحقت بوزاره الخارجيه
اشتغلت لفتره
بوزاره الخارجيه
مكلف بدراسات
في بالضبط من 97 الى غايه 92
من 97 الى 87 عفوا
خمس سنوات
وكنت حينها
ان تسب الى الكليه بنفس الوقت لتهيئ
الدبلوم الدراسات العليا
فاشتغلت مكلفا بدراسات في ديوان وزير
الخارجي حينها عبد اللطيف الهلالي
وهي فتره مهمه اعتقد يعني لانه
شهدت يعني تقلبات كبرى عالميا سقوط
وبدايه نوع من الانفراج في العلاقات
المغربيه الجزائريه وهذا محدد رئيسي في
السياسه المغربيه اكيد
وقد يكون محددا في السياسه الجزائريه كذلك
ولكن على كل حال عشت هذه الفتره والتي
تزامنت معا
انعقاد مؤتمر القمه في الجزائر في 88 كانت
العلاقه مقطوعه
واتى ان لم تخوني الذاكره الامين العام
لحزب جبهه التحرير هو الذي قدم دعوه للملك
الحسن الثاني
شريف مساعديه
وقال الملك مما يعني يعني تم تسريبه بانه
كيف احضر وليس لدي سفاره
فكانت مؤشرا على فتح او اعاده العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين المغرب وكان الملك يريد
ان تكون هناك
فاستانفت العلاقه بتاريخ 8 يونيو 88 لازلت
اذكر هذا التاريخ وحضر الملك الحسن مؤتمر
القمه الذي انعقد في الجزائر في في يونيو
موظفا وطبعا اذكر هذه التواريخ وهاتي
الاحداث
وكانت وكان هذا اللقاء النواه الاولى
للاتحاد او لبعث
انعقد اجتماع بضاحيه الجزائر العاصمه في
منتجع زرالده
مع القاده الخمسه للبلدان المغاربيه
وكانت النواه الاولى فهذا اللقاء لقاء
زرال ده كان النواه الاولى الذي سيتمخذ
عنه طبعا
قمه او مراكش مع عملك الوظيفي ايضا بدات
تحضير الدراسات العليا ثم انهيت الدكتوراه
في رساله اللافت الخطاب الاحتجاجي لدى
الحركات الامازيغيه والاسلاميه لماذا
اخترت هذا الموضوع والشيء من الشيء يذكر
هو انا قلت لك بان المنطقه كانت تعرف
اهتزازات يعني
تكلمت عن حائط برلين ولكن هناك شيء وقع
كذلك في الجزائر يعني مظاهرات اكتوبر 180
نهايه الحزب الواحد بناء تبني التعدد صار
فيه انفراش في المنطقه في الجزائر في
الجزائر وطبعا يعني في تداخل يعني كان
هناك تتبع
وحينها مثل ما قلت لك كنت اشتغل في في
وزاره الخارجيه ومكلفا بملف الاتحاد
المغاربي هذا ملف البعض لم يكن يهتم به
فترك لهذا الملف
وطبعا كنت يعني حقيقه
اريد ان اشتغل على هذا الملف
فكنت اتردد على البلدان المغاربيه
وحصل في يوم يعني ولربما اذكر تاريخ ذلك
اليوم انني عشت في يوم واحد احداث لافته
يعني صليت في مسجد السنه وكان حينها يصلي
به
ويؤم به علي بلحاج وكنت اريد ان استمع
لخطبه من خطب لكن للاسف لم يكن هو الخطيب
وانما كان شخص اخر لازلت اذكره السليماني
فورا وهو
من اصول من تلمسان ولكن مغربي
فورا ذلك طلب مني السائق
ان
اصطحبه الى جنازه قال لي هل يمكن كذا قلت
روح معك
فذهبت معه في حي شعبي في الجزائر
وحضرت الجنازه
وكان يخيل الي انني في اي حي من احياء
المغرب الشعبيه لا شيء يختلف لا شيء تماما
حتى الخط لا شيء تمام وفي نفس اليوم
في نفس اليوم وكان يوم الجمعه
حضرت مظاهره قام بها الحداثيون وبعض
الفعاليات النسويه وحركات امازيغيه
وكان شعارها ان ندافع عن حقوقنا لا زلت
اذكر ان
في
ان ندافع عن حقنا النوث في
اذا ترجمناها حرفيا ان نضرب من اجل حقنا
لكن الفكره هي انو داخل وكان يتراس
المظاهره القيادي الحسين ايت احمد في صوره
يعني تناقلتها وسائل اعلام حينما وقف من
شرفه وهو يعني يترفع بشال احمر هات
الاشياء اثرت فيه
لانني كنت اقف على تماثل البنيه ثقافيه في
اي حي شعبي المظاهره كان يمكن ان تكون في
الرباطه في الدار البيضاء
ولذلك كنت اتساءل هل مستقبل المغرب حاضر
الجزائر هل هذه حركات التكتونيه من حركه
الاسلاميه او الحركه الامازيغيه هل هي
معاني المغرب لان هناك تماثل في بنيه
المجتمع نفس الاشكاليات نفس الغضب نفس
المطاعم الشعور الذي تولد عني انني
حينما كنت احضر جنازه كان يخيل الي انني
فعلا
بالنسبه الي قائما
حينما دخلت من واشنطن وكنت حينها في
دبلوماسيا
يعني بظروف لا حاجه ان نقف عندها
قررت ان اقوم برساله حول هذا الموضوع وكان
الفكره هل سيكون في نهايه المطاف
مستقبل المغرب حاضر الجزائر وانت تعرف
حينها في الظروف التي كانت تمر فيها
يعني الخطابات كانت كانت توجه القائم في
العلوم السياسيه هو دراسه النخب
ان تدرس بعض النقاب او الاحزاب او كذا
ولكن المدرسه الامريكيه يعني اتت بعنصر
جديد وهو دراسه الخطاب فانا لم ادرس في
النخب ولكن درست الخطابات الخطاب الاسلامي
الخطاب الامازيغي فرانكفونيين الى اخر
وقارنت مع
حالات قد تكون متشابهه في في لبنان
وفي الجزائر وانتهيت الى ان مستقبل المغرب
لن يكون لا مستقبل لبنان
كانت هي النهايه التي انتهيت لها في هذه
الرساله واعتقد بانه الاحداث يعني اكدت
اليه من خلال الدراسه حينما تولى الملك
محمد السادس
استعان بزميله القديم دكتور حسن اريد وان
يكون ناطقا باسم القصر
انت كنت تعمل في الخارجي لا حينها لم اكن
كنت اشتغل لوحدي
في الصحافه بالاساس كنت في في اسبوعيه
كانت تسمى لجورنال كانت اختي
الملكه الحسن الثاني بالضبط
توفي الملك الحسن الثاني رحمه الله في 23
يوليو 99
تولى الملك حينها
وكنت حقيقه يعني ادعى من خلال مناظر
اعلاميه
عربيه ودوليه ومنها سينان والحياه ان اعلق
على الحدث وان اشرح بعض النظام من التحول
فكنت حاضرا اعلاميا واستدعيت لاول
مهمه لا ليس يعني اول خروج رسمي للملك
في صلاه اليوم الجمعه تم الاتصال به لكي
احضر مراسم الجمعه لما صادف اول عيد للعرش
يعني في 30
كان هذا هو يعني اذا كان يمكن ان نسميها
اشاره بعده باسبوعين تم تعيين ناطقا رسميا
باسم القصر الملكي بتاريخ 9 اغسطس كيف
تقيم هذه المهمه وتقدر ادوارك فيها
وطبعا كان هناك امل كبير جدا حينها يعني
كان هناك يعني المجتمع المغربي وفعاليه
المجتمع المغربي
كانت تمور كانت تتحرك يعني كان في خطاب
لحقوق الانسان الحركه الامازيغيه الحركه
الاسلاميه
[موسيقى]
فكانت في امال وكانت في مخاوف كذلك
وفكره المصالحه فرحت بشكل كانت تطرح ثم
قبل ذلك يعني الملك الحسن الثاني رحمه
الله تبنى السلسله من اجراءات كانت تصب في
المصالحه دستور جديد في
93 92 عفوا ثم بعد ذلك في 96
انتخابات افضل الى فوز الاتحاد الاشتراكي
وتم يعني الى المسؤوليه لعبد الرحمن يوسفي
ان يكون حكومه وهو المعارض الذي قد شطرا
من عمره في في معارضه نظام الملكي ونظام
ونظام الحسن الثاني يعني هذا الشخص اصبح
من يقود الحكومه الى اخره فكانت هناك
سلسله من اجراءات يعني اساسيه
من اجل المصالحه فلذلك كانت امال كبيره
للواقع
انه حقيقه يعني الملك محمد السادس اعطى
دفعه كبيره لهذا التوجه يعني بدا من دون
شك مع الملك الحسن الثاني ولكن تولي
السادس محمد السادس اعطاه دفع قويه فيما
يخص ملف حقوق الانسان فيما يخص عوده
المهاجرين كان مثلا قضيه
المعارض
المغربي
ابراهامستر فاتي نزعت منه او كادت تنزع
منه الجنسيه المغربيه اعتبر انه غير مغربي
ملك محمد السادس اتاح له ان يرجع معزز
المكرما برنامجك زياره منطقه الريف كانت
في اشاره قويه اكيد انت دكتور لما توليت
مهمه الناطق ومهمه حساسه لانها تعبر عن
القصر وعن الملك ايضا ليس الحكومه مكان ما
البرنامج اللي كان مطروح
ما الذي يراد ايصاله هو ايصال بالاساس
مصالحه ربما يمكن
يعني ان نلخص ربما قد اكون مجانبا للصواب
ان نلخص هذه الفتره في الحداثه مجتمع
حداثه
يتصالح مع نفسه
يطوي ملفات الماضي
ومنها ما علق من اختلالات
وانتهاكات لحقوق الانسان لاعتراف بالحقوق
الثقافيه
طبعا وكان اول شيء هو زياره الملك
محمد السادس
لمنطقه
الريف وقبله خطاب مهم جدا كان القاه في
الدار البيضاء من اجل مفهوم جديد للسلطه
كانت حقيقه فتره واعده
يعني وكان ينظر الى المغرب كتجربه رائده
ربما كذلك ربما ينبغي كل شيء لانه كان
هناك كذلك امل
في التطبيع وفي المصالحه مع الجزائر لكن
هذا الامل للاسف لم يتحقق
ساتحدث عن هذه المساله كم استمريت في
المنصب استمريت الى غايه 2005 يعني ولا
حاجه الى ان نقف عند مكناس
كانك ابتعدت قليلا عن دائره ممكن ان ننظر
الى ذلك كانوا عاده البلاط يعني اي بلاط
في قصور الحكام بشكل عام يكون هناك صراع
وتنافس هل يمكن القول انه تم ازاحه
الدكتور حسن بعيدا
اظن ذلك يعني ولو ان هذا الامر يعني لم
يعد يستاثر باهتمام اظن ذلك اظن وان الامر
بدا
قبل ذلك
طبعا
اظن بانه في العمل السياسي
من المعقول والمنطق ان يكون الانسان
مسؤولا عما يقوم به
اي خطا يتحمل مسؤوليته
ولكن لست ارى من الحكمه ولا من المنطق ولا
من العدل ان يكون مسؤولا عما يتقول عنه
هذا غير مقبول تم التحول يعني
اشياء طبعا تم ترويجها
بناء على تكهنات او ما تهواه الانفس
او مكائد او على كل حال فانا طبعا
اظن بانه من الحكمه ومن المنطق الاشياء ان
يكون الانسان مسؤولا
عما يقوم به ان اخطا ولكن ليس من الحكمه
ان يكون مسؤولا عن شيء لم يرتكب يعني انا
انا لا علاقه لي بالبيان الامازيغي
ولم التقي عناصر من الشبيبه الاسلاميه في
باريس
ولم احرض الصحافه ضد وزير في قضيه اثيرت
الى اخره فهذه على كل حال انتهى بك الامر
بعد ولايه مكناس الى ناطق الى مؤرخ رسمي
للمملكه سنه واحده من 2009 الى 2010 تماما
ما هذا الدور كان غريب انا حقيقه للامانه
لم اكن متحمسا لهذا المنصب
باعتبار الذاتي وموضوعيه وكنت عبرت عن ذلك
وكان هذا الشعور نابعا من خشيه ان يكون
لقب فقط
وللاسف الشديد ما كنت اخشاه هو الذي وقع
كان حقيقه يعني مجرد لقب وطبعا لكي اكون
وفيا
للتربيه التي تلقيتها في المدرسه المولويه
استحضرت
هذا البيت الذي حفظته وكان الملك الحسن
الثاني يردده وهو للحطيئه كان المرحوم
الحسن الثاني يقول بان اهجى بيت قالته
العرب هو بيت الخطيئه دع المكارم لا ترحل
لبغيتها فانت الطاعم الكاسي فلم اكن اقبل
ان اكون مجرد طاعما وكاسيا والا ارحل
ابتغاء المعالي فلذلك يعني طلبت طلبت فثم
طبعا لم تكن هناك وسائل للعمل وعلى كل حال
هذه صفحه وانتهت بهذه الصفحه التي طويت
نطوي صفحه هذه الحلقه الجزء الاول والذي
والتي اشرنا فيها الى مسيرتك حقيقه تحتاج
الى حلقات لكن اردنا يعني مرورا سريعا ما
لا يدرك كله لا يترك لا يترك جله
سننتقل في الحلقه الثانيه للمحطات الفكريه
في مسيره الدكتور حسن اريد انتاجه الفكري
وانتاجه الادبي والشعري الغزير يقول
الزملاء الدكتور حسن ينتج يعني يعني كلما
غبت عنه قليلا انتج كتابا هذا ليس المعيار
الجوده
المثقف الذي طلق يعني السياسه من بوابه
العمل مباشر او طلقته شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور
حسن شكرا سعيد جدا بوجودك وموعدنا في
الحلقه القادمه ايضا لمزيد من الحديث حول
كل هذا الانتاج وحول هذه المسيره الفكريه
اللافته لمثقف مغربي ترك بصمته بشكل واضح
في العالم العربي شكرا الشكر لكم انتم
مشاهدينا الكرام على طيب المتابعه القاكم
ان شاء الله الاسبوع المقبل في حلقه جديده
دمتم بخير وفي امان الله
[موسيقى]